hello there and welcome to the show and
look we're gonna do something a little
bit different tonight our whole show is
actually gonna be about one thing and
you probably know what and you probably
know why because all week long
protesters have continued to fill the
streets in all 50 states in the wake of
the horrific murder of George Floyd by
the police and in response to those
protests which have been a stirring
pushback against institutional racism
and brutality has been frankly sickening
to see them met with this across the
country peaceful protests have to often
devolved into standoffs with heavily
armed police using military style
tactics
flashbangs tear gas rubber bullets
helicopters armored vehicles we're out
here peacefully protesting but there are
what they're going toward yeah they are
and look if police are trying to
convince the public they're not guilty
of displaying excessive force it's
probably not a good idea to repeatedly
display excessive force on national
television including in this city where
Mayor DeBlasio praised them for their
tremendous restraint and Governor Cuomo
threatened to send in the National Guard
and I'll say this having recently said
that I couldn't wait to go back to
hating Andrew Cuomo again I didn't think
the opportunity would come quite this
soon and these protesters have received
a great deal of support with massive
marches taking place all around the
world and the protesters message has
taken many forms from chance to signs to
a man who called into an LA Police
Commission meeting held over zoom now
he'd been given 30 seconds which he used
with maximum efficiency to deliver a
message for police chief Michael Moore I
find it disgusting that the LAPD
slaughtering peaceful protesters on the
street I had two friends go to the
protest in Beverly Hills it a couple
days ago
and the protest was peaceful so the
police showed up with their excessive
violent force shooting rubber bullets
and throwing tear gas is this what your
figure protected in Surrey because I
think it's you Michael
Moore I refuse to call you an officer or
chief because you don't deserve those
titles you are a disgrace
suck my dick and choke on it I yield my
time you if the president is taking
notes that is what a perfect call looks
like my favorite part is that after he's
finished unloading on that police chief
he yields his time realizes he still has
a couple of second
left so unyielding and throws in a bonus
you now as for the president
himself he initially hit from the
protesters in the bunker later claiming
he wasn't hiding he was actually just
inspecting it then his attorney general
had please gas protesters outside the
White House so that chunk could have an
inexplicable photo op and a nearby
church while holding up a Bible like
it's the ticket for a sandwich order
that was just called he also in
announcing job numbers on Friday invoked
George Floyd's name saying this was a
great day for him which is utterly
disgusting but were actually not
going to focus on Trump tonight nor are
we unlike some in cable news going to
dwell on the incidents of looting that
occurred except to say if you said the
name Macy's more than you've said the
name Brianna Taylor this week you can
very much off likewise if you ask
your wife spontaneous decentralized
protests can't control every one of its
participants more than you are asking
the same about a taxpayer-funded heavily
regimented paid workforce you can also
in the words of this generation's Robert
Frost sucked by dick and choke on it
you instead tonight let's talk
about the police because all week we've
seen graphic videos which are going to
be hard to watch of them driving
directly into crowds beating people with
sticks and sometimes assaulting the
right to assemble with shocking speed
and barbarity prematurely shoot people
prematurely using excessive force no
scary ass on somewhere
it's genuinely impossible to overstate
how enraging that is they're protesting
excessive force by police and the police
just stop pepper spraying them like it's
sunscreen and that's just one of
hundreds and hundreds of videos and
we're taping this Saturday morning who
knows what will have happened by Sunday
night maybe they'll be using grenades
even as the New York Times weighs in
with an op-ed titled
why we need to bring Hitler back to life
as a robot right now they just think
it's valuable that you read that point
of view I mean they didn't but they
think that you really should and look
for any of us sitting at home shocked by
the scenes of police brutality I get it
I'm white too but it's worth remembering
that's the tip of a very large iceberg
it didn't start this week all with this
president and it always
disproportionately falls on black
communities because here are some hard
facts in Minneapolis where George Floyd
was murdered police use force against
black people at seven times the rate of
whites black Americans are
two-and-a-half times more likely than
whites to be killed by police and about
one in every thousand black men can
expect to be killed by police if you're
black in America I can't even begin to
imagine how scared angry and exhausted
you must feel not only this week but
constantly medical groups say police
violence against black and brown
Americans is just one of many physical
and psychological factors that make
racism a serious public health issue and
look clearly the police are just one
part of a much larger system of racial
inequality but for tonight we're going
to focus primarily on them and try to
address three basic questions how the
we got to this point what the
obstacles to reform have been and what
we can do going forward and let's start
by just acknowledging that the police
have long enjoyed an exalted role in
American society in pop culture they're
the heroes of beloved movies and TV
shows like cranky gun grandpa and
cocaine cops who and manic bigots
and is one black friend America loves
nothing more than a renegade cop who
doesn't
by the rules but of course the reality
of policing is and has always been very
different and it might be worth going
through some of the history here because
it's important to understand how deeply
policing in this country is entangled
with white supremacy and I know you
might be thinking well join the club
policing this is America the only
institution not deeply entangled with
the history of white supremacy is Olive
Garden and that's only because it's
always been a powerful symbol of white
inferiority but the police have not just
been incidentally tainted by racism for
much of US history
law enforcement meant enforcing laws
that were explicitly designed to
subjugate black people some of America's
first law enforcement units were these
slave patrols tasked with capturing and
returning people who'd escaped from
slavery and when slavery ended white
people had no intention of letting that
be the end of white power as one Alabama
planter said in the wake of emancipation
we have the power to pass stringent
police laws to govern the Negroes this
is a blessing for they must be
controlled in some way all white people
cannot live among them and I know that's
uncomfortable to hear it's certainly
uncomfortable for me to say but if we
want to talk about how we got here it's
important to remember that we got here
on purpose now for a century after that
police in the south are responsible for
enforcing segregation while allowing and
sometimes participating in lynchings and
anti black terrorism and as black people
migrated to the north by the millions
they were met there yet again by
brutality and all of this coupled with
the continued denial of economic and
housing opportunities not always
particularly subtle by the way meant
that by the summer of 1967 there were a
series of high-profile uprisings against
racial injustice across the United
States or as white people actually
describe that exact time the summer of
1967 it is known as the summer
yeah it is known as that and that's a
pretty big disconnect isn't it and it
honestly makes me slightly worried that
what's happening right now will be
remembered one day by white historians
as the summer of chromatic err and look
things did not improve from the 60s on
with Nixon pledged fealty to law and
order and started the war on drugs which
Reagan later turbocharged and by the
time we got to the nineties a school of
thought called broken windows or zero
tolerance policing had started to take
root which help it if minor crimes are
left unattended it will lead to more
serious crimes
therefore please have better crackdown
on those minor offenses that fueled the
saturation of police in low-income
communities of color and gave way to
policies like stop and frisk which
essentially allow police officers who
searched people at random at that
policies peak in 2011 of the nearly
700,000 stops recorded in New York the
vast majority were of black and Latino
people or to put that another way those
policies too often basically mounted to
this just under a
different name and that's sort of
aggressive policing was accompanied by
constant calls to increase the number of
police officers on the streets and let's
be clear here Democrats were very much
involved in that from big city mayors
all the way on up to this guy an
initiative to put 100,000 more police
officers on the street more presence
more prevention a hundred thousand more
police 100,000 new police in communities
of all sizes we need to finish the job
of putting a hundred thousand more
police on our streets
last fall Congress supported my plan to
hire in addition to the hundred thousand
community police we've already funded
fifty thousand more concentrated in high
crime neighborhoods yeah thanks very
much for that Congress 100,000 police
officers isn't cool you know what's cool
massively expanding a broken institution
to score cheap political points and if
you can do that while playing the
saxophone
well that just gets even cooler and all
the while as we were continuing to boost
funding for police and give them more
authority we were simultaneously
slashing spending on key social services
that meant that in many communities the
police were the only ones left to handle
almost
any issue that people had which is a
real problem as this former Dallas
police chief readily admits we're asking
cops to do too much in his country we
are we just asking us to do too much
every Society of failure we put it off
on the cops assault not enough mental
health funding get the cop hammer not
enough drug addiction fun let's give it
to the cop here in Dallas we got a loose
dog problem that's had a conversation
with dogs you know what he's absolutely
right we are asking police to do far too
much they have a massive array of
complicated duties that in many cases
they just aren't equipped to handle
making them very much the Jared
Kushner's of local officials without of
course the expression complexion and
general demeanor of a haunted baby so
while we should absolutely be angry at
the police right now let's also be angry
at this series of choices that left them
as essentially the only public resource
in some communities and on top of all of
that we've made those bad choices even
more dangerous in recent years by
needlessly arming police to the
teeth as we discussed six years ago now
we've issued the police literal
military-grade equipment some of which
you've seen used to control and
intimidate protesters this week and it's
frankly not just a hardware that's a
problem here because a whole sub
industry of police training has also
cropped up to reinforce the message that
cops are at war and perhaps no one takes
that idea further than this guy once
you've made the decision to take a human
life your transform creature your
predator
what does the predator do they kill only
a killer can hunt a killer are you
emotionally spiritually psychologically
prepared to snuff out a human life
in defense of innocent lives if you
can't make that decision you need to
find another job Wow
you know the problem with telling
someone that they're a predator is that
it Prime's them to see the rest of the
world as potential prey and of course
cops who went through this training
could wind up on edge you wouldn't train
a barber by saying here is scissors snip
like this and oh yeah this is how to
puncture the carotid artery now you
won't need to use this 99% of the time
but if you don't think you can make that
decision you need to find another job
now that grouse man is actually called
Dave Grossman and he calls himself an
expert in kilala ji a term that he
invented and defines as the scholarly
study of the destructive act just as
sexology is the scholarly study of the
procreative Act which oh and also I'm
pretty sure that the first lesson in
sexology is never call sex the
procreative Act if you want anyone to
pro creatively act with you ever again
and as batshit as Grossman is he is by
no means a fringe figure in police
culture he's on the road giving
trainings 200 days a year
the officer who shot falando Castille
had taken a class based on Grossman's
theories and went in the wake of that
shooting the Minneapolis Mayor banned
officers from participating in warrior
style training the head of the police
union there Bob thrall announced plans
to defy that decision if they deem that
this training is in violation and
they're on their own time and they want
to attend it I'm gonna encourage
officers to do it I myself will be the
first one to do it if I would be
disciplined it would never be upheld I
honestly don't know what's more alarming
there his determination to train police
officers to be predators his air of
casual impunity or the fact they has a
sign in his office that says let me drop
everything and work on your problem
which is always the office decor choice
of a grade-a but especially if
it's someone who
actual job is to work on other people's
problems and that confidence that he's
above punishment actually brings us to
the second point that we want to look at
tonight what the major obstacles to
reform have been because one of the
biggest issues is police unions even in
cities where the mayor and police chief
say all the right things it's important
to know that the union can stop whatever
they are proposing dead in its tracks
and unions can make it incredibly
difficult to discipline officers even
for egregious misconduct take what
happened in Minneapolis with two
officers who belonged to our friend
Bob's Union to Minneapolis police
officers are on paid leave for allegedly
decorating a Christmas tree at the 4th
precinct with a bunch of items that are
viewed as racist bags of hot tacky chips
a cup from Popeye's fried chicken
menthol cigarettes and cans of malt
liquor among other things holy that
is not just disgusting it's also
arguably the most racist thing to happen
to Christmas since people decided that
this child's born in the Middle East was
white and not only does that incident
raise serious questions about those
officers it also implicates the entire
precinct because they presumably thought
that none of their co-workers would have
a problem with what they did and to his
credit when that story broke the mayor
of Minneapolis announcing the officers
responsible would be fired by the end of
the day only to have to almost
immediately walk that statement back say
that there was a process that they were
required to go through by law we
actually checked and despite the fact
it's now been a year and a half since
that happened one of those officers
cases is still under arbitration and
look I get union's fighting for their
workers that is what they do but police
unions take that to a dangerous extreme
and negotiate language into contracts
that makes removing a problem officer
incredibly difficult a Washington Post
analysis of some of the nation's largest
police departments found that they fired
at least eighteen hundred and eighty-one
officers for misconduct but were forced
to reinstate more than 450 of them
that's almost 25 percent after appeals
required by their union contract and
police unions can also oppose even the
most basic common-sense reform a few
years back the Cleveland Police started
be required to file a report every time
they unholstered and pointed their gun
at someone and their union head was
absolutely furious
I'm afraid that officers are going to be
hesitant to pull their gun in an
appropriate situation because they don't
want to do the paperwork that's gonna be
associated with having to pull your gun
okay first the idea that the risk of
paperwork is a greater deterrent to
police officers drawing their gun than
the risk of killing someone is
legitimately terrifying and it's hard to
take that glib dismissal from anyone let
alone someone who looks like a Boyles
mr. Potato Head or an angry egg with a
moustache and I know those comparisons
probably make him mad but what's he
gonna do shoot me I don't think so think
of the paperwork involved and that
attitude is particularly hard to take
considering that just six months
previously Tamir rice had been killed by
a Cleveland police officer and when
faced with accountability that they
don't like unions will often issue the
ultimate threat to simply pull back and
let crime rise for instance listen to
help ahead of New York City's largest
police union reacted where the judge
recommended firing the officer whose
chokehold led to the death of Eric
garner the criminal advocates have
gotten what they want the police
department is frozen the police
department can't stop the killers they
can't stop the criminals they can't
effectively do their job I'm sorry to
say that we have to tell our police
officers take it a step slower
take it a step slower he just basically
threatened in action against the killers
as a bargaining chip and besides that
being morally reprehensible it is a tool
that most labor unions simply don't have
at their disposal when the unions
representing TV writers fight for their
members the worst thing that they can
threaten the public with this few
episodes of bull or the blacklist or
this show and that's just not a
compelling argument and that wasn't even
an empty threat because following that
statement policing did slow down in New
York for a bit last year there was an 11
percent drop in felony arrests and 18
percent drop in misdemeanor arrests and
a 32 percent drop in moving violations
but the thing is if you lived in New
York then
you probably don't remember it as the
time that the city devolved into chaos
because it didn't
people still went about their lives
subways were still as delayed as they
usually were and rats still dragged
slices of pizza upstairs to feed their
rats families after a hard day of rats
work making you wonder whether all those
arrests were really in the interest of
Public Safety at all now one good way to
attempt to get reforms passed a unions
resistance is if the federal government
steps in which actually can it has the
power to investigate police departments
for a pattern of civil rights violations
and enter what is called a consent
decree in which the police department
agrees to make institutional changes
that are then overseen by a federal
court that can be a powerful tool to
force change in fact that paperwork
requirement in Cleveland that pissed off
this egg that came from a consent decree
the problem is how or even whether the
government does that depends on who is
running it and right now it's this
wildly unsuccessful Bible salesman and
he clearly has no interest in police
reform in george w bush his first term
his Justice Department launched twelve
such investigations into police
departments in a bombers first term it
was 15
Trump's DOJ has launched just a single
investigation and has entered zero
consent decrees meanwhile Trump himself
has made it pretty clear where he stands
on the police use of force
he not only rolled back Obama's
restrictions on giving the police
military equipment just listen to what
he said to an audience filled with law
enforcement please don't be too nice
like when you guys put somebody in the
car and you're protecting their head you
know the way you put their hand like
don't hit their head and they've just
killed somebody don't hit the head I
said you can take the hand away okay
Wow you know it's bad enough when it's
just a bunch of random
cheering on Trump's lawless rhetoric
it's a lot more alarming when that
applause is coming from the people whose
main job is to see lawlessness and stop
it
so if the union's won't act and the
federal government won't act what else
can you do as a civilian to get
accountability if the police violated
your rights well you could try and Sue
the city or the individual officer in
question and in high-profile cases
especially they can be incentivized to
settle for astonishing amounts in fact
over a period of five years the ten
cities with the largest Police
Department's paid out a billion dollars
in settlements and court judgments and
listen I'm no comptroller believe me I
wish I were a hard-to-explain lethally
boring elected accountant whose title
inexplicably took a real word and then
stuck and in the middle of it come on
that's my dream jump but even I can tell
you if you're spending a billion dollars
on misconduct settlements you might want
to seriously examine what conduct looks
like and if a city doesn't feel that it
has to settle with you you're in real
trouble because civil suits against cops
are nearly impossible to win just listen
to a defense attorney explain one reason
that it was gonna be difficult for
Michael Brown's family to sue the
Ferguson officer who killed him
civilly sure they could go after him
civilly the problem is he has qualified
immunity he's gonna say that I was
acting within a scope of my employment
this is what I was doing yeah and he is
right about that
police officers are often protective in
consequences due to something called
qualified immunity which sounds like
something you get from a horrifying
cheatcode in Grand Theft Auto well guess
what I turned on qualified immunity and
now my car runs on prostitutes but it's
actually worth taking a moment to talk
about that term theory basically
qualified immunity means that a public
official is immune from lawsuits unless
their exact conduct has already been
ruled unconstitutional in a previous
case and I do mean exact because small
tiny variations can result in the case
being thrown out this happens all the
time
for instance one case was thrown out
because of the difference between
unleashing a police dog to bite a
motionless suspect in a bushy ravine and
leasing a police dog to bite a compliant
suspect in a canal in the woods which I
totally get those are two completely
different kinds of outdoor holes and
then there was this case a federal
appeals court has ruled Seattle police
used excessive force when they tasered a
pregnant woman during a traffic stop in
2004 she was shocked three times with a
stun gun for refusing to sign a speeding
ticket although the ruling was in
Brookes favor the officer who fired the
taser was given immunity because the law
on stun gun use was not clear yet that
is absolutely ridiculous the method the
officer used to assault that woman
clearly shouldn't matter it's like if
Jeffrey Dahmer was declared innocent
because he cooked his victims in an
instant pot the crime is the killing not
what appliance he used now the
good news is there is a chance that the
Supreme Court will soon decide to
reconsider qualified immunity this
there's actually a bill in Congress
right now to abolish it although even if
it passes it may have to wait for a new
president to sign it and we may not get
one of those anywhere from the next four
years to never
but while ending qualified immunity
would be great that alone isn't going to
be nearly enough and that brings us to
our final point here what do we do now
there are a lot of suggestions to look
at unfortunately some prominent
Democrats have been spitballing ideas
that are embarrassingly small and
perhaps normal ridiculous than this and
the idea that instead of standing there
and teaching a cop as an unarmed person
neighbors are my shooting the lair
instead of the heart there's a very
different thing there's a lot of
different things Wow
that lack of imagination is not
particularly inspiring but also not
particularly surprising coming from Joe
Biden who is truly the getting shot in
the leg instead of the heart candidate
right now well that's obviously absurd
the instinct of the Biden just displayed
there that the key question is not if an
officer should shoot someone but where
he's shared by many politicians in New
York Bill de Blasio has balked at making
it illegal for police to use choke holds
despite the fact that a chokehold is
precisely what led to the death of Eric
garner but the fact is the incremental
reforms that we've tried like the wider
use of body cameras and implicit bias
and use of force training are not on
their own going to cut it I'm not saying
that we shouldn't still try them but in
many cases you're contending with an
entrenched police culture resistant to
any effort to compel reform that is why
many are advocating that we rethink
police from the ground up one small
example of this is Camden New Jersey
which 10 years ago was pleased by a
deeply troubled corruption ridden force
but in 2013 they dissolved their City
Police Force entirely with officers
having to reapply for their jobs and in
doing that they've been able to
meaningfully shift the culture while
also instituting policy changes that
relate to both a drop in excessive force
complaints and some rebuilding of
community trust and look I'm not saying
that it's been easy perfect or even that
it would work everywhere but it should
expand our idea of what is possible one
even broader idea that's gaining
momentum right now is defunding the
police now that's a phrase that on its
face may sound alarming to some in fact
just watch this professional alarmist be
alarmed on his very bad face defund the
police no more cops that's what they're
fighting for that seems like a fringe
position but in the Democratic Party it
isn't anymore if you live in a gated
community
it might sound like a good idea you've
got your own police force you have no
plans to replace them with Rapid
Response social workers
you're set no matter what happens there
are gonna be any rapes on your street
but what about everyone else what's
gonna happen to them okay first of all
in all sincerity Tucker you seem nervous
this is a difficult moment and I really
hope that you're taking time for
yourself and whether it's through
meditation or yoga or just kidding
you forever Tucker Cal said you sentient
polo mallet second given the shockingly
low number of rape cases that actually
result in charges much less convictions
I really wouldn't be holding that up as
proof that our current system is working
well and finally defunding the police
absolutely does not mean that we
eliminate all cops and just succumb to
the purge instead it's about moving away
from a narrow conception of Public
Safety that relies on policing and
punishment and investing in a
community's actual safety net things
like stable housing mental health
services and community organizations the
concept is that the role of the police
can then significantly shrink because
they are not responding to the homeless
or to mental health calls or arresting
children in schools or really any other
situation where the best solution is not
someone showing up with a gun that is
the idea behind defund the police if you
actually listen to it which suggests
that Tucker Carlson has the exact level
of understanding about the black lives
matter movement that you would expect
from a man who always looks like he just
saw his first black Barbie and feels
confused but mostly scared and look as
we know many police will likely resist
any redistribution hard police unions
often paint themselves as essential and
everything else as somehow frivolous in
fact remember Bob Kroll but when
Minneapolis offed his Union to accept a
pay freeze due to Kovac 19 here is how
he reacted the first thing we said was
okay let's see the budget let's see the
city budget and guys they're pissing
away millions and millions of dollars to
projects like you know they're given
$15,000 a year to the transgender
operator burn City all right so let's
set aside the risks of violence against
transgender people particularly trans
women of color and instead consider that
the budget for the Minneapolis Police
Department is
193 million dollars meaning that 15,000
amounts to 0.008 percent of their annual
budget and if that's pissing money away
the city should really see a
urologist but guys like bob rolling his
eyes and anything transgender related is
exactly why it is time for our
conversation to go beyond how should the
police do their jobs to what really do
we want the role of the police to be and
too many still seem to think that this
is an issue of a few bad actors in fact
just listen to one officer
unsuccessfully try to make that argument
to some protesters just this week yeah
that protesters right what the does
that mean because one hamburger should
mean a health inspection a few bad
hamburgers might mean that McDonald's
getting shot down and bad hamburgers
regularly killing people on the street
would mean that we've maybe all consider
going vegan but this clearly
isn't about individual officers it's
about a structure built on systemic
racism that this country created
intentionally and now needs to dismantle
intentionally and replace with one that
takes into account the needs of the
people that it actually serves and this
is gonna take sustained pressure and
attention over a long period of time
from all of us black communities have
had to be perpetual activists while also
routinely
being disenfranchised and it is long
past time that the rest of us joined to
make sure that their voices are heard
and acted upon because it's going to be
far too easy for nothing to meaningfully
change here that is what has always
happened before after the unrest in the
late 60s a commission was set up to
investigate and issue advice many of its
conclusions resemble ideas like a police
demilitarization and broad reinvestment
in marginalized communities that are
still being pushed today that testify
before that commission was the social
scientist Kenneth Clark and he made this
observation which remains depressingly
true he said I read the report of the
1919 riot in Chicago and it's as if I
were reading the report of the
investigating committee of the Harlem
riot of 1935 the report of the
investigating committee of the
right of 1943 the report of the Macomb
Commission of the Watts riot of 1965 I
must again in candor say to you it is
the kind of Alice in Wonderland with the
same moving picture of rish own over and
over again the same analysis the same
recommendations and the same inaction
we're in the same now that we're in
back then and if you're not directly
impacted by it it is tempting to look
for a reason to feel better about the
world to look at some cops kneeling and
think oh well we just need more of that
but we need so much more than that
because ours is a firmly entrenched
system in which the roots of white
supremacy run deep and it is critical
that we all grab a shovel to do
anything less would be absolutely
unforgivable and actually to that point
there's one person I saw this week whose
words have been echoing around my head
and you've been listening to me talk for
a while so now I'm gonna let her have
the last word tonight so when they say
why do you burn down the community why
do you burn down your own neighborhood
it's not ours we don't own anything we
don't own anything there is Trevor NOLA
said it so beautifully last night
there's a social contract that we all
have that if you feel or if I steal then
the person who is the authority comes in
and they fix the situation
but the person who fixes the situation
is killing us so the social contract is
broken and if the social contract is
broken why the do I give a
about burning the Football Hall
of Fame about brother the target
you broke the contract when you killed
us in the streets and he give up
you broke the contract room for 400
years we played your game and built your
wealth you broke the contract when we
built our wealth again on our own by our
bootstraps ain't OSA and you dropped
bombs on us when we built it in Rosewood
and you came in and you slaughtered us
you broke the contract so your
target your Hall of Fame
far as I'm concerned it could burn this
to the ground and it still
wouldn't be enough and they are lucky
that what black people are looking for
is a quality and not revenge that's our
show thanks for watching good night
you